gym câline ce n'est très content de
t'avoir au bac et steve nu faire en
france eh bien cette fois je suis venu à
paris pour faire la couverture du
magazine the best mais je suis en france
très souvent en fait je de maisons dans
le midi par des mots oui c'est ça
progrès moi j'adore comment ce pays si
je pouvais j'ai passera le plus clair de
mon temps
le pays auquel je suis plus attaché
cependant c'est l'angleterre c'est mon
plein data je ne suis pas américaine
tout le monde pense que je suis
américaine
la cause des dynasties mais je suis
anglaise après avoir été à mon pays
préférés c'est la france c'est quoi qui
te prennent plus en france j'aime
beaucoup le midi de la france
un provence sa pole devant nice cannes
saint-tropez
paris est une ville que j'adore quand je
suis ici je vais beaucoup dans les
musées dans les magasins je prends
énormément de plaisir à faire du show a
pu y aurait dit qu'est ce que tu déteste
le plus en france est douce je dois dire
qu'il ya quelques chauffeurs de taxi qui
compte un peu trop vite à mon goût mais
à new york c'est encore pire au début de
ta carrière honte à comparer à marilyn
monroe elizabeth taylor tu as travaillé
avec des gens comme moi richard fleisher
ou cardio lio macquarie mais plus tard
ça n'a pas marché aussi bien pourquoi il
ne faut rien exagérer tout de même
en fait ce que l'on peut dire c'est qu'à
l'époque les actrices elles poussaient
comme de véritables champignons ramassés
puis j'aurais porté aux nues et pour
finir on s'en débarrasser à tout casser
une actrice tenait
six sept huit ans même les plus célèbres
celle dont on se souvient encore edith
la mare janeiro un vol que très peu de
temps lorsque mon contrat avec la twenty
century fox et arrive à son terme au
bout de six ans j'ai pensé que le moment
était venu de fonder une famille de
devenir une véritable mère de famille et
de m'occuper de mes enfants
et c'est ce que j'ai fait à ce moment là
ta carrière était complètement fini non
enfin tu pensé rester chez toi écrire et
c'est là qu'on t'a choisi pour dynasty
non ma carrière n'était pas fini voilà
encore une idée reçue pour la plupart
des gens si vous n'êtes pas une star
vous n'êtes pas une actrice
il ya des centaines et des centaines
d'acteurs et d'actrices quand beaucoup
de succès qui peut être ne figure pas
très souvent sur les couvertures de
magazines quand on parle peu dans les
journaux mais qui néanmoins fait une
carrière honorable et vivent de leur
métier
j'ai toujours réussi à vivre de mon
métier d'actrice même si je n'étais pas
dans les meilleurs films du moment je
m'en sortais très bien je travaillais au
western théâtre à londres et je n'étais
pas une grande star mais c'était pas
très important pour moi d'être une
grande star pourquoi et comment tu as
choisi pour dynasty
j'avais déjà travaillé pour aaron
spelling un an avant il était alors
producteur de fantasy island
il cherchait donc une actrice pour le
rôle et aaron se souvenait de moi il
m'avait tout est bien c'est quelqu'un de
très franc si bien qu'ils m'ont
téléphoné mais ça tombait un peu mal
parce que j'étais sur le point de
commencer à jouer dans une pièce à
londres le contrat à terme signés et
j'ai eu d'énormes difficultés pour
réussir à me de commander et puis
surtout je me disais que cette série
dynasty
ça n'allait durer vu quelques mois
jamais je n'aurais imaginé que sept ans
plus tard je serai toujours en train de
faire maintenant tu tournes toujours
pour dîner ce type à ce que j'ai entendu
dire qu'ils avaient des problèmes qu'on
voulait de faire mourir dans une rivière
et finalement vous étiez tombés d'accord
sur lequel chine avait accepté de
continuer ça c'est encore des articles
de presse à bon marché
en gros ça c'est toujours plus ou moins
bien passé
bien entendu il ya des moments où il
devient nécessaire de discuter un peu
non il ne voulait pas me faire mourir le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que los
angeles il ya une grève des scénaristes
si bien que je ne sais pas quand on va
recommencer à tourner en août ou en
septembre peut-être mais en ce qui me
concerne je vais encore faire 11
épisodes et puis j'arrête parce que je
vais écrire montre peut-être que dynasty
continuera j'en sais rien mais en tout
cas n'y aura plus d'ici combien par
épisode tu te crois quand même pas que
je vais répondre à cette question et toi
combien tu gagnes l'indiscrétion aux
états unis tout le monde parle de blé
sans trop de problèmes oui mais moi je
ne suis pas un week-end je suis en quête
comme toutes les grandes stars
d'hollywood on parle beaucoup de tes
histoires d'amour qu'elle était
amoureuse
enfin c'est un secret pour personne
harry belafonte de warren beatty de ryan
o'neal de thermostats amoureux ce n'est
pas vraiment un j'utiliserai je dirais
plutôt que j'ai fait je les ai connus
mais certainement pas que tu peux pas me
faire un p'tit et hop tu es préféré
messieurs chirac
non je ne veux pas ça ne serait pas très
bon goût y'en a bien quand même
non n'insistez pas sur ce sujet après
son divorce avec peter hunt a dit qu'il
voulait plus jamais être mariée c'est
vrai oui je ne vois pas pourquoi je me
remarierai je ne voulais pas me marier
avec secteur mais il a tellement insisté
pendant des années françoise sagan elle
a dit si on vous aime pour votre argent
c'est pas un problème faut bien composer
pour quelque chose tu en penses quoi
je pense qu'elle a parfaitement raison
je pense que c'est très profond mais en
ce qui me concerne on ne m'a jamais aimé
pour mon argent car on a commencé à
m'aimer bien avant que je n'aie de
l'argent en france au questionnaire qui
s'appelle le questionnaire de proust de
marcel proust dans leurs ressources à
des questions du genre c'est quoi pour
toi le comble du malheur
pour moi le comble du malheur c'est de
voir les autres souffrir
would you like to vivre à londres
le voleur pour toi c'est quoi que toute
ma famille reste en bonne santé et soit
heureux c'est quoi le défaut que tu
pardonnes le plus facilement
en croix de feu québec je pardonne assez
facilement le défend que je pardonnerai
plus facilement
quant à celui que je pardonne avec le
plus de difficultés c'est sans doute la
fidélité c'est quoi tes romans préférés
dans les hauts de hurlevent et scarlett
o'hara dans autant en emporte le vent
avec sky anexis carrington et puis aussi
sans doute le personnage de clouer dans
le roman que je viens d'écrire
il sera publié qu'en ce moment il a déjà
été publié aux états unis il le sera en
angleterre au mois d'octobre et en
france en novembre décembre ou janvier
c'est autobiographique c'est l'avis de
cinq actrices elles se battent pour un
rôle dans une série télévisée
on y parle surtout d'une des actrices
c'est un peu romanesque
cela permettra de se faire une idée de
ce qui se passe dans les coulisses de la
télévision aux états unis est un
personnage historique préféré c'est qui
marie-antoinette marie antoinette des
héroïnes d'aujourd'hui madame thatcher
d'angleterre et mère teresa
elle était l'héroïne dans des ouvrages
de fiction
je viens juste de répondre à cette
question j'ai dit cathy dans les hauts
de hurlevent ce qui concerne les pièces
de théâtre mon rôle préféré c'est amanda
private life donald kohn
j'ai toujours joué trouvé ton peintres
préférés
j'en ai beaucoup musicien quoi les tours
un homme la qualité que tu préfères son
sens de lowell pour une femme
sa vertu favori en face ils n'ont
probablement la fidélité son passe temps
favori
pureté dans les magasins d'antiquités au
delà qui aurait tué med par exemple si
je n'étais pas actrice tu veux dire
j'aimerais être soit journaliste soit
romancière soit décoratrice kouadio a
plu et en quoi tes amis nouveau je
dirais qu'il soit fidèle au ton plus
grand défaut défaut la patience what
would be au peg astana penas ton plus
mauvais souvenir lorsqu'un de mes
enfants est tombé gravement malade et
enfin la couleur préférée
leblanc la fleur préférée la rose est un
écrivain que tu déteste par dessus tout
l'hypocrisie le cas doute que tu
voudrais avoir de la nature
l'immortalité
j'en attendais pas loin comment tu
voudrais mourir
aucune question horrible comment je
voudrais mourir je ne voudrais pas
mourir rapidement qu'elle est à présent
ton esprit je dirais pas mal pas mal ta
devise
ma devise avoir le beurre et l'argent du
beurre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu